how's it going everybody it's Warren and
at the end of Avengers in game we
finally got to see Captain Steve Rogers
get his dance with Peggy Carter and even
though we finally got to see Captain
America get his happy ending many fans
were sad and even mad that we won't be
seeing him in the MCU anymore
despite Chris Evans's contract to play
Captain America being over in him not
renewing it many fans were really
wondering why they decided to end the
story arc for Steve Rogers as Captain
America but in an interview the writers
of infinity war and endgame Christopher
Marcus and Stephen McFeely told us why
Steve thought it was time to retire and
hang up his shield I'll break down why
they said he retired in this video but
first a quick reminder about my giveaway
at the 450,000 subscriber mark I will be
picking three winners and each will get
to choose one item from the Marvel
Legends series collection all you have
to do to enter is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain so of
course after the release of Avengers in
game the cast the writers and the
directors have been doing a ton of
interviews talking about the movie and
in the interview with variety
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
asked why did Steve Rogers / Captain
America finally feel like it was his
time to retire and according to them
obviously Steve Rogers thought that it
was time to retire but here's what they
said on why here's what writer
Christopher Markus had to say about why
captain retires Steve's over 100 years
old he has fought World War two and
Civil War and infinity war and he has
come to a place I think where he's
realizing he needs to take a little time
and be a little healthier in a way I
think when he encounters his old self
back in Avengers tower there is a
processing going on in his head that
well that's a really intense and maybe
not 100% healthy guy so I think it's
time Captain America has always been
selfless he has always been about
everybody else putting other people's
needs before his own and what the
writers are saying is that that can get
a little unhealthy but we kind of see
Steve change over the films as his story
art develops which was also another
reason that Steve Rogers decided that it
was time for him to retire writer
stephen mcfeely addressed this in the
same interview he said we figured out
pretty early that Toni and Steve were
sort of on criss-crossing arcs
Tonie movie by movie was having a more a
macro view becoming more selfless and
Steve was becoming a bit more
self-interested civil war is a good
example of that so we had put up on the
wall at one point Tony becomes a
complete person when he loses his life
and Steve becomes a complete person when
he gets one we drove toward that which
is exactly what we saw play out in
Avengers in game in the beginning of the
movie Steve had a talk with Natasha
about how he couldn't move on but at the
end we saw him finally passed down the
mantle of Captain America to Sam
completing his story arc and of course
we saw our beloved hero Tony Stark
finished his story arc by performing the
snap and saving the entire universe
so that is why according to the writers
of Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame Steve Rogers thought that it was
time for him to focus a little bit more
on himself and retire and go back and
live with his love Peggy Carter he was
finally able to move on with his own
life so let me know what you think about
Steve Rogers as reasons for a tiring are
you glad Captain America finally got the
ending that he deserved or do you wish
that he would still continue to be in
the MCU let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and again another
reminder about my giveaway at the
450,000 subscriber mark I will be
picking 3 winners and each will get to
choose one item from the Marvel Legends
series collection to enter all you have
to do is be subscribed to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain
I'll also be starting giveaways on my
Instagram and Twitter if you want to
follow me on social media as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
your